>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
WILL THE MIDTERMS HAVE PELOSI
WISHING FOR A CUSHIE DIPLOMATIC
POSITION?
TRUE WHILE AMERICAN VOTERS FUME,
PELOSI EYES ITALY TO LAND HER
BROOM.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TAKE THAT DR. SEUSS.
HOUSE SPEAKER AND NOTED EYEBROW
HERDER NANCY PELOSI WANTS
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO NOMINATE HER
TO BE THE AMBASSADOR TO ITALY.
THAT'S A COUNTRY KNOWN FOR
DiGIORNO AND OTHER FINE FROZEN
PIZZAS.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A REPORT
FROM FOX BUSINESS WHICH IS OWNED
BY OUR PARENT COMPANY SUN GLASS
HUT.
APPARENTLY IF REPUBLICANS REGAIN
THE HOUSE IN THE MIDTERMS,
PELOSI WANTS TO GO SOME PLACE
ELSE RATHER THAN THE BAY AREA
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS THE NUMBER
ONE SPORT OF HUMAN FECES.
SO WHY NOT ITALY?
TRANS I WILL VEIN I CAN'T IS
ALREADY FILLED B IF THE GOP WINS
MAYBE SHE JUST DOESN'T WANT TO
BE MINORITY LEADER ANYMORE.
SHE ONLY LEADS MINORITIES IF THE
DESTINATION IS POVERTY.
THE U.S. HASN'T HAD A SENATE
CONFIRMED AMBASSADOR TO ITALY
SINCE TRUMP'S ENVOY LEWIS
ICEBERG LEFT THE JOB IN 2021.
I WAS WONDERING WHAT LEWIS
EISENBERG WAS UP TO.
TALK ABOUT A BARREL OF LAUGHS,
LEWIS.
ANYWAY, ENOUGH ABOUT HIM.
ANYWAY, ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
190 AMBASSADOR POSITIONS ARE
OPEN, INCLUDING COLUMBIA, TO
WHICH HUNTER BIDEN SAID [BLEEP]
YEAH I'LL TAKE IT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: NOW PELOSI COULD ALSO
BECOME AMBASSADOR TO
AFGHANISTAN.
BIDEN GAVE TALIBAN MISIN WEAPONS
SO WHY NOT SEND THEM ANOTHER OLD
BATTLE ACTION.
GOOD OLD JOE IS APPARENTLY
HOLDING ROME FOR HER EVEN THOUGH
SHE'S ON TRACK TO WIN HER 18TH
TERM IN SACK.
18TH TERM.
SHE'S HARDER TO GET RID OF THAN
THAT FONDUE SET YOU GOT AS A
WEDDING GIFT FROM YOUR GREAT
AUNT.
ALTHOUGH A SPOKESMAN SAID THE
SPEAKER HAS NO NOTION IN THIS
POSITION AND HAS NOT DISCUSSED
IT WITH ANYONE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
RIGHT.
YEAH WE KNOW IT'S HERS IF SHE
WANTS IT AND WHY WOULDN'T YOU
WANT IT THE AMBASSADOR'S
RESIDENCE IN ROME HAS ITS OWN
POOL AND A THREE STORY WINE SELL
CELLAR WHERE SHE CAN LOCK HER
HUSBAND IN.
SPEAKING OF HE'S ALREADY
LEARNING TO DRIVE STICK ON THOSE
ITALIAN-MADE CARS.
SO IRRESPONSIBLE OF TYRUS.
DOESN'T IT BOTHER YOU THAT SHE
CAN PROBABLY JUST GET -- SHE'S
EIGHTY -- GO HOME, LADY.
>> Tyrus: YEAH, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY -- JUST GO, JUST
LEAVE.
>> Greg: JUST LEAVE.
DO YOU NEED THIS?
>> Tyrus: YEAH, SHE DOES.
>> Greg: SHE CAN AFFORD TO FLY
TO ITALY ON HER OWN TIME.
>> Tyrus: THERE'S A LOT OF
UPSIDES GOING TO ITALY.
FOR HER HUSBAND.
BEING THE TOWN DRUNK IS
FASHIONABLE.
HE CAN WALK AROUND WITH HIS
GLASS OF WINE AND, OH, HE'S SO
CUTE JUST DON'T LET HIM DRIVE.
YOU KNOW?
BUT THIS IS THE PROBLEM, THIS IS
WHY WE NEED TERM LIMITS SO BAD
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tyrus: SHE IS GOING TO BE IN
SOME OFFICE FLEEING TAXPAYERS
FOR SOME SALARY TILL SHE DIES
AND EVEN WHEN SHE DIES, SOMEBODY
WILL STILL BE VOTING FOR HER.
LIKE THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH
POLITICS.
IT'S THE ONLY JOB, AND I'M NOT
AGE SHAMING HERE, ESPECIALLY FOR
MY LITTLE FAN BASE, BUT LISTEN,
IF YOU WERE A 95 YEAR OLD BUS
DRIVER, THEY'RE GOING TO SEND
YOU HOME.
>> Greg: YES, EXACTLY.
>> Tyrus: IF YOU'RE A 95 YEAR
OLD SENATOR, THEY'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO SOLVE WORLD PROBLEMS
IN BETWEEN NAPS AND APPLE SAUCE.
UNBELIEVABLE.
LISTEN, YOU MIGHT BE A SPRY 95
YEAR OLD BUT I'M GUESSING
THERE'S A 60 YEAR OLD OR 50 YEAR
OLD THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE A
LITTLE BETTER PREPARED.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE POINT.
I THINK PEOPLE MISUNDERSTAND OR
FORGET EMILY THAT JOBS ARE LIKE
ANYTHING.
THERE'S A LINE OF PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF YOU AND AT A CERTAIN
POINT PEOPLE -- WHETHER YOU'RE A
PROFESSOR OR A TALK SHOW HOST OR
WHATEVER, SOMETIMES YOU'VE GOT
TO SAY MAYBE OTHER PEOPLE SHOULD
GET A CHANCE.
BUT THERE WERE PEOPLE LIKE THE
CLINTONS AND LIKE THE PA LOWSIES
AND THAT WHOLE FAMILY, THE
NEWSOMES, WHATEVER, THEY WILL
NOT GET ANYBODY GET IN.
THEY'RE HOLDING ON FOR DEAR
LIFE.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT AND I
THINK EVEN IF THE PERSON DOESN'T
HAVE THAT HUMILITY THE SYSTEM
SHOULD AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT
IT DOESN'T.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THOSE
MACHINES HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE,
THE CLINTON MACHINE AND THE
GETTY MACHINE AND THE FIVE
POLITICAL FAMILIES IN SUFIC THAT
SUPPORT THOSE SAME PEOPLE THAT
ALSO SHARE TARGETS.
THEY SHARE WHO THEY SUPPORT.
SO KAMALA HARRIS'S DONOR BASE IS
THE SAME AS GAVIN NEWSOME'S AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S ONE BIG INCEST
WITH US MESS.
THE FACT I'M FROM THE BAY AREA
AND SAW IT TURN MY CITY TO
[BLEEP] AND MY FAMILY IS FROM
ITALY AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE
HER TURN THAT INTO [BLEEP].
>> Greg: SO TRUE.
>> Emily: I CAN'T WATCH THAT IN
ITALIAN WE CALL THAT -- [BLEEP].
>> Greg: IS IT [BLEEP] OR IS IT
[BLEEP].
>> Emily: THAT'S DEATH
>> Greg: IS ISN'T IT NO IT'S
POOP.
>> Tyrus: IT'S FRENCH, OUI, OUI.
>> Greg: WAIT UNTIL THE BREAK.
>> Matt: TO HER POINT THIS IS
THE PROBLEM WITH CONGRESS AND
WHY WASHINGTON, DC IS BROKEN.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY FOR 35 YEARS
THAT HAS PUT IN THESE LIBERAL
POLICIES, HER HOME STATE HAS
SUFFERED AND NOW SHE WANTS TO
PARACHUTE OUT TO A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY TO POSSIBLY MAKE THAT
WORSE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS HAD A DIFFERENT
EXPECTATION.
THAT WAS, YOU WOULD GO, SERVE
FOR A LIMITED TIME BECAUSE IT
WAS AN INCONVENIENCE.
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, IT WAS NOT A
HOT TUB THAT YOU COULD SOAK IN
AND SOAK THE TAXPAYERS.
AND THEN YOU WOULD GO HOME,
AFTER A LIMITED INCONVENIENT
SERVICE AND LIVE UNDER THE LAWS
YOU PASSED.
AND WE NEED TO GET BACK TO THE
CITIZEN SERVANT MODEL AND NOT
THE CITIZEN FLEESER
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THEY WORK FOR US, AND
THEY WORK FOR US TEMPORARILY.
>> YEP.
>> Greg: MARTHA THIS JOB HAS
BEEN OPEN FOR A LONG TIME
>> Martha: YEAH.
>> Greg: SO THAT MEANS IT'S
BEING HELD FOR SOMEBODY RIGHT?
>> Martha: ABSOLUTELY.
AND YOU REMEMBER WHEN SHE WENT
AROUND MEMORIAL DAY ON HER BEACH
VACATION?
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ALL REMEMBER
HER WALKING DOWN THE BEACH WITH
HER LOW-CUT BATHING SUIT AND ALL
OF HER FRIENDS CHATTING WITH
ANDRE A BOW CHILLY ABOUT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT.
PAUL WAS WITH HER I'M SURE
HAVING A GREAT TIME IN ITALY
WITH THE WINE AND THE VEIN 0.
I KEEP THINKING WHEN I LOOK AT
THAT BEAUTIFUL VILLA, ALL THE
AMBASSADORS LIVE IN THOSE
BEAUTIFUL PLACES.
OF COURSE SHE WANTS ITALY AND
NOT AFGHANISTAN.
IF SHE REALLY WANTED TO SERVE
SHE WOULD SAY PLEASE ACCEPTED ME
WHERE YOU NEED ME THE MOST.
SHE WANTS TO GO HERE.
REMEMBER THAT IMAGE OF HER
OPENING UP THE DOUBLE
REFRIGERATORS AND THEY WERE
STACKED WITH THE MOST EXPENSIVE
JENNY ICE CREAM IN THE WORLD.
SHE'S LIKE WE HAVE 50 FLAVORS OF
EVERY -- SHE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO
STOP DOING THIS.
HILLARY DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO STOP
DOING THIS, THEY'VE NEVER DONE
ANYTHING ELSE AND TO YOUR POINT,
THE FOUNDING FATHERS DID NOT
HAVE THIS KIND OF TENURE IN
MIND.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF THEY
WROTE IT INTO THE CONSTITUTION
ABOUT THE CITIZEN SERVITUDE,
CITIZEN SERVICE, BUT IT'S TIME,
IT IS TIME TO GET FRESH BLOOD
INTO THESE SITUATIONS.
I RESPECT PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER
AND HAVE EXPERIENCE BUT IT'S
TIME FOR HER TO HAVE THE
HUMILITY, AS EMILY SAYS, YOU
KNOW, IT'S BEEN A GREAT RUN I
HAVE SERVED AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR ME TO MOVE ON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT JUST
STRUCK ME
>> Martha: THERE'S NOT A BONE IN
HER BODY LIKE THAT.
NOT A BONE IN ANY OF THEIR
BODIES LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: WHAT IF THE FOUNDERS
DID THIS AS A LASHING, THEY
DIDN'T EXPECT IT TO GO FAR.
>> Tyrus: LIFE EXPECTANCY WAS
LIKE 50 BACK THEN?
SO IF A BEAR DIDN'T GET YOU
WHILE YOU WERE RIDING YOUR HORSE
TO THE CAPITOL.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
WHY CAN'T I BE AN AMBASSADOR I
WOULD BE A GREAT ONE
>> Martha: WHO DOESN'T WANT TO
BE AT THE VILLA.
>> Tyrus: WHERE WOULD YOU BE THE
AMBASSADOR.
>> Greg: SOME PLACE CLOSE.
>> Tyrus: CANADA
>> Greg: NO, THE BAHAMAS.
THEY HAVE THEM RIGHT?
>> Tyrus: SURE.
I'LL PUT YOU ON THE BOAT AND
PUSH IT
>> Martha: LOTS OF VERY
COMPLICATED NEGOTIATIONS.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
YOU NEVER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WAR, THE WEATHER'S GREAT.
THAT'S WHY SHE DID ITALY.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
THIS BOTHE